let's see what's going on with our
caller from the 202 area code caller
from 202 who's there
what's on your mind today hello yes
that's you okay um I wanted to comment
on I think some of the backlash you got
from your AOC coverage okay what's your
name
Oh Valencia okay and there's something
going on in the background there I don't
know if it's my own voice feeding back
or what but if there's anything you can
turn down there that would be great okay
that is my voice now I'm realizing well
I just wanted to say I think some of the
criticism that you received I don't know
if anybody quite made this argument but
basically a lot of the attacks that AOC
gets are like on their face racism
sexist and a part of that attack of her
is discrediting her intelligence so when
you make commentary about her that in
some ways ties into that narrative of
questioning how intelligent she is I
think people really get up in arms about
that and that's all the one that they
kind of so once you that's it I'm glad
you're bringing this up to me let me
when you sew a mic her when some if you
were to say that something is racist
against Alexandria Casio courts has
which which race would we be talking
about okay and so if I understand your
argument correctly you're saying that
there could be people who perceive my
criticisms of Alexandria Casio Cortez as
a sort of assumption that as a Hispanic
woman she might be less intelligent or
something like I'm not saying you're
saying I think that but you're saying
that that could be interpreted in that
way yeah I don't think it's necessarily
because I said majority people who do
your videos know that that's not the
case but when I think people are very
protective
her and excited about her policy so that
they're very willing to come at anybody
who even a little bit sounds like
they're making an argument like that and
especially about the intelligence all
because every you know that like she was
part of the reason that people that's
how they'll take her down oh she's an
idiot like I think they even saw an
article that compared her to like left
Sarah Palin that she will eventually be
you know be the real idiot that she is
so when the critique of her policy is
like kind of questioning whether or not
she understands the issues at hand it
kind of sees into that general narrative
of question her intelligence which is a
product of the racist and sexist attacks
that she gets now you're saying equating
her to Sarah Palin Sarah Palin's
intelligence was also questioned and as
far as I know Sarah Palin's white so but
can you make the case for why when you
critique Sarah Palin's intelligence race
isn't a factor but if someone critiques
a o'seas it would be assumed that it's
partially because of her race like why
would that be telogen question is
because she made it she made it said
things that were questionable like I
could see Russia from my house and you
know stuff like that there didn't really
support the idea that she was a serious
policy or politician but hey OC also
made some policy misstatements yes but
okay yeah that's another part I feel
like well that's the key partner right
that's why I made a critique because she
said things that were wrong right I feel
like the question is whether she
understood a until to the level that I
feel like you did it which i think is
just my good old toe can come off a
little it's very direct which is why
people like but so you're inferring from
the tone of how the questions were asked
the motivations may have been partially
because of her Hispanic race well I'm
not talking about specific video fits
into the larger narrative and I think
that's why the backlash is no song I
don't think anything I was particularly
egregious I'm saying that that just you
in a sea of people are judging these
types of arguments against it that's why
the backlash is so strong just not the
truth what you were so awful in this
Turk that it is a part of a broader
attack so when people feel that she's
being attacked they attack back it is I
think you are so terrible
right the comments were so ridiculous
should it make any difference in how we
interpret the attacks so like I'm an
immigrant from Argentina I spoke Spanish
as my first language and then you know I
emigrated to the US and I spoke Spanish
at home and then I learned English is
that identity piece of factor in whether
a critique of mine of a Hispanic woman
would be understood to be racist like
would my identity matter in that I think
it does but I think hopefully this is in
you know a rude thing to say but I don't
think read necessarily is Hispanic when
people come across your conscious where
she con mio Cortez so that's like front
and center she makes that a part of her
branding I think that piece is always
there with you know I don't know just
people coming across your video with
necessarily categorize that's fair
you're absolutely right I mean they
wouldn't but I think that this is the
problem of getting into these identity
games because when we say a critique of
Alexandria Castillo Cortez could
realistically be seen as possibly
motivated by the idea that Hispanic
people are less smart but similarly a
critique of Sarah Palin wouldn't be
because she's white but what if the
critique comes from someone who's
Hispanic but what if the person doesn't
appear to be Hispanic at first glance I
think this is why I'm just not sure that
this is even a good path to go down
No
I think you definitely get into the
weeds when you're talking about like
every little you know in a sexual marker
and trying to describe these
conversation in that way but I do feel
like like the things that I've laid out
previously are like real-world factors
and how people in purposes okay it's not
but I think that it's the right thing
like just think it's real and people I
don't like the identity politics all bad
cuz you get into the weeds about what
the reason what they are important
because people who look previously on
represented in these faces feel so
strongly just at the representation that
they get even if the person isn't you
know the best I'm on board with that and
I made it clear that's why I think
identity is important now when it comes
to this specifically and my particular
critique might we all have been better
off if you called in and we merely
discussed the substance of what my
critique was you agree that we might
we're also working through like you know
dealing with different people with
different backgrounds and all that kind
of stuff so it's so important to like
call out what how that affects the
issues as well like certainly the policy
issues are important but like that's
like half the reason why you know this
stuff that it goes all right now those
races of the beautiful via of God old
trumpet is administration is obstructing
like the bells except that which is you
know a part of what also if I quite how
I was been real Cardinal quickly they
put me in jail all right all right
that's fair but but I do think it's
interesting that you're you're at least
partially conceding that as or more
important than the perception of my
critique based on a o'seas Hispanic
identity would have been just a
conversation about the policy and I
think that it's important that you're
recognizing that oh yeah I don't that's
what my token was is like I don't think
you're certainly it's a right to make it
and I don't think their critique was
particularly ridiculous or harsh it's
just that in the climate that we live in
critique of her will get do that winners
and people on her side or they really
could protect her even if they're not
know well I think that's the problem in
other words that's a real problem which
is that people are defending someone
even if she's wrong on the policy
because of the cult of personality I'm
critical of that when it's Trump or and
I have to be critical of it when it's
Bernie or AOC or whoever listen I
appreciate the call it sounds like we
agree on some stuff although we may be
disagree on some others but I appreciate
you sharing your thoughts with me all
right Valencia thank you and on that
note I'm out of time for calls we will
take calls again appreciate everybody
calling in today